this independence day will be marked in
part by protests many focusing on police
practices and in that there is a
remarkable connection with the document
we celebrate today a close reading of
the Declaration of Independence suggests
it's as much about Britta the British
Army's unfair policing practices over
colonists as it was about taxation
without representation in fact ongoing
demands for fairness justice and
equality are as old as the nation itself
expressed in protest through the
generations American protesters have
always used the 4th of July as a symbol
particularly the Declaration of
Independence as a way to say to the
nation you have not lived up to your
ideals Syracuse Women's History
professor Carol Faulkner pushback is as
American as American Pie UPenn political
science professor daniel gillian the war
against dehumanization is ceaseless an
LGBTQ activists Matt rhymer all insists
our founding is oh so complicated so how
important his protests been in is making
America what it promised to be it's
fundamental it's important to kind of
define what we mean by protest
queer existence at least visible queer
existence is in and of itself protests
how de marginalized groups like women
like african-americans get a voice in
this nation it's through a protest
rebellion broke out five years before
the Revolutionary War six years before
independence was officially declared all
of the issues that were still grappling
with now or an issue in the American
Revolution what is the place of black
people what is the place of women in the
country and people who do not
necessarily fit the mold the wind they
spoke about their freedom while at the
same time keeping blacks enslaved here
was sort of a conflicting conundrum that
original sin preserving the institution
of slavery provokes some of the first
protest movements from slaves and
abolitionists alike and pushback was
fierce and violent repercussions for
those activists the best example is in
1838 Pennsylvania Hall abolitionists had
to build their own building so they
could have somewhere to speak and a mob
of over 10,000 people surrounded it the
first week it was built and burned it to
the ground when black and white women
were holding a convention inside to talk
about the abolition of slavery but while
violence has so often been used to
suppress calls for change it's also been
employed by the change agents themselves
what role has violent protests played in
this country I always say that
nonviolent protest brings about
awareness and violence and protests
brings about urgency where individuals
have to focus in and pay attention to
these unconcerned I would give the
example of John Brown and his raid on
Harpers Ferry anti-slavery movement had
been struggling for decades and John
Brown concludes with his allies that
only violence only a direct attack on
slavery and it did not succeed but he
was also a martyr to the cause even
before it succeeded the fight against
slavery gave birth to
another liberation movement when women
were barred from the world anti-slavery
convention of 1840 within the
anti-slavery movement people thought
women should shut up politics was not
woman's purview they should stay out of
it
Lucretia Mott said it's activists
obligation to stand out in heresy in
order to challenge the status quo and to
call attention to all its hypocrisy
and falseness the push for equal and
civil rights suffered setbacks but also
eventual triumphs winning the right to
vote for women and for African Americans
after sustained decade-long marches the
landmark civil rights and voting rights
acts which offered greater access to
immigrants and people in other
marginalized communities still leaders
kept pushing the needle King moved on to
protesting against the Vietnam War
I can imagine lyndon b johnson has
thrown his hands up saying and there's
another concession that i have to make
it was around that time another protest
movement shook our world the 1969
Stonewall riots are recognized as the
start of the gay liberation movement but
in fact the fight for acceptance was
underway decades before as Reimer
chronicles in his book we are everywhere
and his social media posts we start to
see communities organizing that's
relatively small but it is intense and
and vibrant and it builds up into the
mid-century in the mid 60s you see the
first protests out on the street and
what is uniquely empowering potentially
about our community is that we are
everywhere and everyone every race age
class ability because while these myriad
movements have come far they seek to
travel even further as seen after the
Supreme Court's extension of employment
protections to the LGBTQ workforce last
month we didn't see the same outpouring
of joyousness it's a huge ruling but it
was almost immediate there was a
response within the community what's
next
we are seeing progress but that progress
is not to the point that leads to
complete equity I think the American
public has come to see as just normal
double-digit unemployment in the black
community that's normal being harassed
by police that's normal and it comes to
a point where protest has to put these
issues in the forefront and say hey this
is not right this is not fair how long
is it going to take before we are a more
perfect union if we were ever content to
suddenly we should be worried about
ourselves you don't have to be Martin
Luther King you don't have to be
Lucretia Mott you don't have to be
Harvey Milk but you might be I think
what is most important right now is is
that people understand that they need to
stay in the struggle and you know Jeff
those protesters in the 60s really
accomplished a lot with the passage of
the Civil Rights Act with immigrants of
color in particular 20th century law and
policy prior to prioritize European
immigrants from entry and outright
banned others including the poor and
those with mental or physical
disabilities and then of course came the
civil rights movement fascinating piece
of history there Michelle nice job